the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
what do you think are some important new
concepts that we've been talking about
in the last week
make a list Betsy
okay all right
virtual work
coming out
keep generalized coordinates anything
else on your list
okay Raj kraines
that's pretty good list any yeah talk
about a few new things lately so is
there any do you come in here today with
any questions about something that's
just because it isn't sitting right
you know on these topics or anything
else and I think right up a couple extra
questions that we may be able to cover
them as we go along
Stephen so this is really how to so you
come how to use the equations you end up
with inter in practical situations okay
the I'm just going to answer this one so
when you choose your generalized
coordinates you'll probably choose about
the same ones you'd choose if you did
the direct method so if you did direct
method would you have this and got court
it got they got questions of motion
would you be asking the same question
right okay so it really you want to
choose coordinates that are going to be
practically useful in the end okay and
so it shouldn't matter whether you're
doing it by Lagrangian method to get to
them you're going to use them the same
way in the end and in fact how I now the
we have two methods to get equations of
motion now when you're doing tough
problems complicated problems I would
always do it one way and use the other
way to check it I'd end up doing it both
ways in if it's really important you do
it both ways and one will give you
insight about the other you know the
yesterday is in lecture is talking about
does it make sense to have a a Coriolis
term in this equation you would you
expect it you know in that kind of
common sense checking all right any
other questions good question generalize
coordinates or forces or anything all
right let's get on this
keep working here so I have an
assignment for you and it's here
this is a familiar problem that you've
worked before by other methods and you
did in fact even find the kinetic and
potential energies I think last week for
this so here's our cart with the rod
uniform rod no - pot at the moment I
know it's no external forces the I'm
going to give you coordinates to use so
here's our inertial system deflection of
the cart X rotation of the rod theta
we're going to break it into groups boy
we've got about we had a big group here
at a big p5 10 mm well that's we'll just
do I want break you into three groups
kind of like five or six there five or
six there and the same thing here and
one group each this group in the front
left computed kinetic energy this system
and the group behind them compute the
potential and this group over here come
up with the velocity of G and V G dot V
G the velocity squared okay and what
this won't take you long because you've
done this stuff before and then when you
get done somebody from your group just
when you're done come up and write it
down all right
let's sort these out stop so let's start
with the velocity we're going to we're
going to need the velocity to be able to
write to do the
then finish out the kinetic energy so
the vector right and the police then
you've broken it into two pieces and
since the others if you haven't worked
on it are you guys I was about to ask
you about that good I think that's
that's better so this is sign right I
hope I didn't traced it and look at that
scho top right you've got this is your L
theta dot piece and you on it this way
and that stayed it so student B sine
theta J cosine theta
yeah okay I think that's good for the
velocity and then velocity squared just
the square of each of the square of each
of the pieces right
Oh
okay so we have VIP we need to put this
into the kinetic energy expression but
we it's one at a time here
the potential energy expression half KX
squared everybody good with that that
looks like the spring connecticut spring
potential energy and m2 g 1/2 al is the
position on of the center of mass one
minus cosine L that times that one minus
cosine theta is a mount that it changes
height from the reference what's the
reference position what have you assumed
for the reference position in this
formulation yeah what it's just after
your reference position it met center of
mass when its hang straight down okay
great so there's your potential energy
kinetic energy expression
how do people have everybody comfortable
with that
Oh
I'm not totally comfortable with it
let's let's come up let's talk about a
minute about kinetic energy and say
what's what can we use what formulas can
we use here for tea you know there's
totally general and then we can narrow
it down yeah what do you suggest Oh
you can take gets taken to account
that's not something about math so you
use the generalized formula 1 hat maybe
over 2,000 points okay so we have some
general formulas and let's just this to
kind of take a step by step approach
with this we have how many rigid bodies
to and what you compute the kinetic
energy for each one individually it's
the safest way to go about this so I
would stay away initially from doing
this your lumping the two together okay
so I would take the two individually so
if you take the main mass the big the
block on wheels
what is its velocity
his velocity is this ex top right and
it's kinetic energy is okay so for the
first block you have m1 X dot squared
and you're done that's the first block
now you need the second rigidbody so the
second rigidbody you could do I mean the
full general expression is one-half m2 v
g in o dot v g in o plus 1/2 omega h
right with respect to g you could you
good with that vicente okay
you need transpose okay good all right
that's the end u n is that can we can we
simplify that at all either you know is
it for example is it wrote that rod
rotating about a fixed point that's not
the point it rotates about moves right
so you can't say it's just you can't use
for example parallel axis theorem and
just say it's one-half i with respect to
that point theta dot squared won't work
can't use that one you will find that if
you work this out you can say one-half i
with respect to G Omega squared in this
problem will work out it will come out
to that because this is a planar motion
problem and there's only one component
of rotation so this will work out to be
a half I with respect Zizi of m2 with
respect to G Omega Z squared in this
case theta dot squared that's what this
term will reduce to but don't assume it
just out of the box and then you need
this term and that's why we need BG
you need to do that put that piece in
over there okay so we have so we need to
so what is I is easy about g4m to run
slender rod so m2 l squared over 12
that's what you need to put in here we
have an expression for V over there and
we okay we have everything we we know
everything now okay so now let's apply
our Lagrange equations and I'm going to
need to rearrange the board here a
little bit I'm going to need that board
space so our key is one-half m1 x1 dot
squared or x squared plus
F M - V G B G
okay and now I can cover this up all
right now so the next task is let's
workout let's try a little duo going
around your equations work so how many
generalized coordinates we have and what
are they
X and theta right that we've chosen two
degrees of freedom cut they're complete
independent whole anomic and we can use
Lagrange equations we're going to come
up with two equations of motion and
we're going to apply this that's the
garage equation we're going to apply it
twice where L is defined as T minus V if
you just plug in L into this expression
and just expand it you get instead of
two terms you get four terms because you
have these two guys and this term what
can you for mechanical systems what can
you say about this term generally that's
the derivative of V with respect to Q
dots two velocities why
no just that you find that for
mechanical system Springs and gravity
you will never find that the potential
energy is a function of time or velocity
just isn't and if it's not a function of
velocity you take a derivative of the
respective velocity you get zeros so
this is this goes to zero for mechanical
systems an exception for non mechanical
would be like a charged particle in a
magnetic field then the forces have yet
to get involved with velocities and so
forth it gets messy zero for mechanical
system so we really don't have to deal
four with three terms that one that one
that one and then on the right hand side
our generalized forces so I'm going to
we have we can break into four smaller
groups two groups are going to do the at
the X equation you have to take these Q
J's and this problem are q1 is X and q2
is theta so we need for the X equation
we need to do these derivatives and for
the theta equation
we need to do these computations so we
can list to have one group a do these
group B do these and Group C do these
and a D group do those so break
yourselves into four groups and we'll do
a b c here in the center group here four
or five or five or group here the C
group and D group over here okay do
these calculations and let's get our two
equations of motion and when you end up
when you get your stuff done so the a
group when you finish come up in right
here write your stuff in the B group
write your answer here and C group in
the D group as soon as you get it done
come up and put it down okay we got this
term this term this term and this term
okay did you guys check you guys a
little bit a little time to be group to
check on the a group
which one was it who's checking on whom
here you're checking on it what do you
think
okay so main mass acceleration set the
second mass its total acceleration these
pieces and there's an acceleration
that's oil air in and there's an
acceleration that is what's this term
related to expected to come up right
okay and our K X term and all these are
going to equal to the generalized forces
and on any non conservative forces so
you're okay with this one let's move on
to this one then who's a check group
here wait hey or do you think it's a
problem here all right let me give me an
alternative it may be that there later
there should be in the time derivative
all right so we need D the derivative of
this with respect to theta dot the first
term doesn't give you anything right the
MX dot squared the second the third term
gives you should give you a nice easy G
theta dot theta double dot
eventually right so for sure let's so
this D by DT partial of T with respect
to theta dot so we just run through it
the first term gives us nothing
the second piece up there the third
piece gives us with respect to theta i
ZZ theta dot and no one wipes out the
one half the time derivative makes it
theta double dot so the third term is
going to be a nice easy g theta double
dot and it's the second term that needs
a derivative of this with respect to
theta dot
okay so both terms are going to yield
some stuff right a lot of stuff okay all
right I'm going to write down how this
should work out rather than try to grind
it out real time here
is easy
all right these are the terms that
should appear this is the piece about G
this is the well that's not quite right
that's the piece about G this should be
about right and then this term that's
how it actually should check out do you
agree with me
yeah looks okay and then if we add to
that the m2 G L over 2 sine theta which
is our gravitational potential energy
all of that added together ought to be
equal to Q theta right so let's move on
to looking at the generalized forces for
this problem so I don't know where you
guys went wrong on this but you have any
question we can talk about this for a
minute what would get was Part D T D
theta so
you got to take the partial derivative
of this expression with respect to theta
dot this piece gives you a contribution
right that will be i ZZ theta dot and
you take its time derivative so that's
pretty obvious why why it gives you the
first piece right okay then the second
one when you take the derivative of this
expression with respect to this is T
with respect to theta dot of this part
this expression you get two times what's
inside times the derivative of the
inside with respect to theta dot and
that will give you another L over two
cosine theta and I think you're done
this times this stuff right two times
this times the derivative of the inside
which is well the derivative of the
inside with respect to theta dot should
be L over two cosine theta so you get an
X dot plus L over two theta dot cosine
theta two times that times the
derivative of the inside with respect to
theta dot this is the only term that
contributes is that and then you do the
we've already done the derivative of
this with respect to theta dot wait a
minute we have it this one now we got
another term here so this one gives you
two times the expression times the
this will give you beta l theta dot sine
theta but now you have to take the
derivative with respect to theta dot
which gives you what
another L over 2 sine theta that's not
like this so you end up with a theta dot
L over L squared over 2 L theta L
squared sine squared and you probably
get a theta dot L squared cosine squared
over here and those two add together to
give you a theta dot l squared over
theta dot L squared I guess those
collapse together and you end at those
coming together to give you the other
piece of this
no the derivative respect to theta only
comes in in the potential energy term oh
okay
all right yep you need that and so T
with respect to theta you have you have
to and you do have theta pieces in there
and it does kick out more pieces
no I didn't haven't even done that
prints yet okay so you do that piece a
couple of things cancel and you end up
with so rather than I don't have time to
work it out to write it all up on the
board but the complete solution for this
is posted you know so all the professor
Gossard who teaches at three of the
other three recitation sections
writes these up and post the answers and
so they're on stellar so you get the the
gory details of each of these pieces
okay let's go on to talk about
generalized forces while we have a few
minutes in this the way it was set up
we're there what are the right-hand
sides are there any general for
generalized external non-conservative
forces the way the problem was first
posed none okay so let's put in a couple
let's add a dashpot be here and an
external force here call it f 1 of t so
now what's q QX and q theta once you
will that's an exercise I think you can
all go through but just check with your
groups figure out the generalized forces
and do it you know do it by imagining as
for this one for the X equation say okay
you have a small virtual displacement
Delta X what's the virtual work that's
done we're Delta W then will be a thing
you're looking for Delta X and the same
thing with this is the theta one I mean
the x1 and you get a similar next thing
when you do the one for theta BQ theta
Delta Theta figure out the work done and
that'll tell you what QX into theta R so
the total work of the non-conservative
forces is through these virtual
displacements you can just add them up
so there's a contribution that comes
from a delta X and there'll be another
contribution from the Delta Theta and we
can figure out each piece and you assign
each piece to the equation that goes
with so what is the if you do a small
virtual deflection in the X direction
how much work is done give me a term
here
so work remember is f dot d dot d R and
this D R is a function of our Delta X's
and Delta Theta is and so forth yeah yes
Delta actually happen B that'll be some
work done so the for F force external
force moves through the full Delta X huh
okay and what else okay
so that suggests then we have here this
is f1 of P in the positive y-direction
minus BX dot the opposite direction
times Delta X is a virtual work done by
as you do that okay now how about the
Delta Theta somebody else here how much
virtual work is done by these forces F
and minus BX so the only non
conservative external forces in the
problem of the dashpot and that f
whatever it is how much work is done by
those forces in a virtual displacement
Delta Theta
I'll hand that back there I hear a bid
for zero what other people think and do
those forces move at all because you
make a motion Delta Theta is there any
dr here that results because of Delta
Theta in the direction of any of these
applied forces at the point of
application of these forces do they move
so this force is right here does it move
because you do a Delta Theta nope and
this force applied right here does that
point move because of Delta Theta no so
in this problem then this piece here is
zero Delta Theta and total virtual work
done is that and you sign each piece to
its appropriate equation so QX this is
QX right here Delta x QX belongs up here
these some of these things equals QX and
in the second case
for the video equation it's equal to
zero so let's make it the problem a
little bit harder for a second let's put
a force apply a horizontal force here
we'll call this f2 so now what is the
work done in this system we now have an
additional force what's the what's is
there any work done because of Delta X
this is the real you understand this
this prop this piece then you're really
beginning to understand how you do these
generalized forces QX Delta X is there
is the the generalized force associated
with Delta X is it affected by this new
force because if any work done so I now
cause this little Delta X to happen does
that force do any work assuming all no
other deflections aren't happen right
now right why
so is that yeah I means it is not it's
not allowed to move whatever
instantaneous position and in its frozen
there and in its coordinate but if
there's an X component it can it moves
in X so it's angled like this off the
cart but now Delta X goes this to it
does that force F do any work how much
ok so then when you add that one to it
we end up with a planet in plus
direction and it's exactly in the same
direction as Delta X as no component is
fully it counts the dot product of F 2
is in the I Direction dot Delta X which
is also in the I so you get an
additional contribution of F 2 Delta X
and so now this generalized force has an
F 2 in it how about the other direction
though how about the it's now q theta
Delta Theta
what is it gives you now if you now
freeze X and allow a slight angular
variation Delta Theta does this guy do
any work okay out how much and is it is
it f2 Delta Theta that's wrong in two
ways dimensions are wrong something else
is wrong so let's draw it here's this
thing
here's f2 Delta Theta causes a motion at
this point in what direction kind of
perpendicular to this right so you can
think of it like this and this would be
L Delta Theta is the actual distance
that it moves right and so you can
either say the component of that motion
in the direction of the force or you can
say the component of force in the
direction of that motion we on a dot
product between this and that and this
is Theta so what is the component of L
Delta Theta in the direction of the
force
that's this right here
and that's now in the I hat dot f2i so
our Delta W in the theta direction is Q
theta delta theta equals my f2 l cosine
theta Delta Theta and to solve for Q
theta now these can disappear q theta is
f - L cosine theta are the units right
what are the units of this generalized
force you got to think about that
equation the theta equation we talked
about this before as units of what
okay what are the dimensions of that of
a term that looks like that this comes
from you do it the direct way the
summation of external torques this is
better have units of torque right which
is units of force times distance so
force times distance it better be the
units of this this equation and
therefore that it better be a torque its
force times length a torque of units at
or sure so that's the correct unit and
over here for the X equation do we come
out with the correct unit yeah comes out
force this naturally works because Delta
Theta is dimensionless so the length the
D are the length piece that comes in
your stays with this to give you a
torque over here Delta X has length in
it and you're just left with the force
so you get a force it force X this
generalized force for the X Direction is
a force the generalized force in the
theta directions a moment a torque all
right good so we're officially done but
if you have any who want to ask
questions on this I'll stick around and
we can chat about it